health secretary is with us this morning
matt hancock of course mr hancock good
morning to you 10 million people
are now facing lockdown measures this
morning it isn't a local lockdown
anymore is it
well yes we uh we we did have to take
action announced
yesterday to uh to bring in more
measures
in the northeast and as we've discussed
many times
we're prepared to bring in this local
action wherever we think it's necessary
and um you know with working with the
councils across the northeast
uh we've taken this action uh ultimately
it's to keep people safe yeah um
sage scientists as i said no longer a
local lockdown with 10 million people
impacted
sage is saying a two week national
lockdown next month is the way forward
is that the way we're heading
well what i'd say kay is that
we really do need to come together to
to tackle this virus once again um the
virus is clearly
accelerating across the country we've
got to
take the necessary action to keep people
safe
the number of people in hospital is
doubling every eight days or so
and so you saw the action that i took
yesterday across
the northeast and we will do what it
takes to keep people safe and
this morning we're publishing the
social care winter plan to ensure we
keep people safe
in in care homes which is incredibly
important yesterday i put another 2.7
billion pounds into the nhs
to keep the nhs safe over uh winter
and to expand for instance a e
facilities so they've got the space
given social distancing so we're doing
everything we can
to prepare and and we're absolutely
prepared to take action if that's
necessary okay so an answer to my
question is a two-week national lockdown
as proposed by some members of sage on
the cards next month
well we'll do what is necessary to keep
people safe
um and the first line of defense is that
everybody should follow
uh the social distancing we've talked
about many many times hands facing space
and
and keep that social distancing the
contact tracing system which is working
very well
that is the second line of defense after
that these local lockdowns
and the last line of defense is full
national action
and i don't want to see that but we will
do whatever is
necessary to keep people safe in a very
difficult pandemic
so that is something that you're
considering a national lockdown
well it isn't something that we ever
take off the table but it isn't
something that we
want to see either it is the last line
of defense
but what i'd say this morning kaye is
that the
country once again needs to come
together and
recognize that there is a serious
challenge
that the virus is accelerating
unfortunately
it isn't just cases increasing
it's also the number of people ending up
in hospital
increasing that's mainly and in the
uh mainly the number those sadly ending
up in hospital
are across the northwest of england but
we've seen a rise also
across the northeast and you've seen the
action that i took
yesterday and we're prepared to do
what it takes to keep people safe whilst
also protecting
livelihoods you know balancing the need
to protect lives and livelihoods
and in what everybody knows are very
difficult circumstances
how close are we to a second national
lockdown
well as you know we keep all of these
things under review
and we don't want to have a
national action it's the last line of
defense hence the
very significant local action that i
took yesterday
and we'll be making further
announcements in the normal way
later today doing that work with local
councils
who are right there on the front line
trying to find all the positive cases
that's
very important but we do have to
recognize
that the number of cases is rising and
we do have to act
because we know especially from looking
at other countries that that inexorably
leads to
more hospitalizations and
and sadly more deaths we and that is
what we want to
to minimize and we want to protect
people's livelihoods at the same time
my viewers are on the edge of their seat
this morning listening to you health
secretary
you quote figures at them all the time
not just you but your colleagues in
government as well quite rightly
you make comparisons with other
countries in europe whether it's test
and trace or
the number of cases you've we've know
that 10 million people
are going to be in a localized lockdown
my question to you is
what are you looking at to decide
whether there will be a second
national lockdown next month and how
close are we to that
well what we look at is first and
foremost the number of cases
and secondly the the the survey that's
put out each week on a friday lunchtime
by the office for national statistics
that is the single best
tool that we have because that takes
into account the fact that the number of
tests has been
has been rising which obviously impacts
on the number of positive results that
you
uh that you get through um we also look
at the number of people
being hospitalized with kovid because
that's when it gets very real
um and um and and so they're the they're
the three main figures and we look at
all sorts of other pieces of information
and and data as well
um what i'd say is that i i i also want
to give a bit of hope
and in it we've seen in france and spain
the number of cases really shooting up
but we also saw that in belgium
they had a start of a second spike quite
similar to what
we've seen over the last few weeks here
and then they took action
and then it came down and it came down
because the country
once again came together to tackle the
virus
in belgium for instance they introduced
a rule of five we've introduced a rule
of six
if people follow the rule of six if
people follow
the local lockdown rules in the areas
like in the
uh in the northeast and uh
greater manchester and other parts of
the north west and if pete and
across birmingham and and parts of the
west midlands
if people follow the rules the rule of
six for everybody and then the local
action where that's necessary then we
can come together and defeat this virus
but we do need my question still remains
health secretary if i may given the
criteria and all of the information that
you have at your fingertips
and you're looking at it ahead of later
on today how close
are we this morning to a second lockdown
next month
well what i would say to you and to your
viewers
is that the virus is accelerating
we've seen that number of
hospitalizations increase
and double every eight days over there
secretary you've said that
several times my question on behalf of
my viewers this morning is
how close are we to a second national
lockdown given
all the information that you have at
your fingertips on a minute-by-minute
basis
and my answer to that question is
that a national lockdown is the last
line of defense
and we want to use local action and we
want people to follow the rules
in order to avoid how close are we
though if they don't how close are we to
a national lockdown
do you not know okay
okay the thing is and i want to avoid a
national i understand that everybody
does so how close are we there what do
we
i is it if we carry on as we are that we
will be in a second
national lockdown what's the answer to
my question
to my question well we do need to bring
the number of cases down but the answer
to your question is that we keep these
things
under review i can't give you that
answer now as you well know
so that's why in this very serious
situation
i'm explaining what we do know all the
facts that we do know
and i'm explaining the approach that we
take the figures that we look at
and the and essentially the lines of
defense that we go through
and that's why i'm answering your
question in the way that i am and i
think
you know having gone through this last
nine months now of this pandemic and i
was discussing this all the way through
it
i think your viewers understand that the
approach that the government
takes is to protect lives and
livelihoods
and to take the action that's necessary
my goodness we've seen
that action sometimes at very short
notice
and sometimes we can't say uh
exactly what the future holds because
we're in a pandemic but i can give this
hope which is that if everybody follows
the rule of six
if everybody follows self-isolation if
they
have tested positive or if they have
been in close contact with somebody
who's tested positive
and if everybody in the local lockdown
areas follows the rules
near them then we can control this
virus together but only by the country
pulling together
yeah the head of test and trace program
dido harding that you appointed
said that she did underestimate the
demand
for test and trace present test and
tracing figures second to ninth of
september
uh quarter of a million capacity 81 000
people actually tested
why bother telling us what the capacity
is you know that's like me saying
um i i my capacity is to run a marathon
but i'm pushed to run 5k around the park
i'm sorry i don't recognize the figure
that you give the capacitors are
incorrect
as you say well you've quoted figures
that i simply don't recognize we're
doing over 200 000 tests a day
and we do have that record capacity but
we have seen demand increase
absolutely and the and uh
let me just take you back on that 250
000 tests a day
are being carried out and then they go
to the lab
and how many of those 250 000 are
actually being tested
in the lab
that the measure of the number of tests
done is the measure of
how many are done through the lab so the
labs are working absolutely brilliantly
they're working flat out i've seen some
flack about them in some of the
newspapers that is wrong
we're hiring absolutely and we're
getting more resources in on the
logistical
side we're putting more uh of the
machines of the
of the testing machines in uh and we're
hiring people so that that capacity
continues to grow
okay so just to clarify because
obviously there's a lot of confusion
over this health secretary so thank you
for
taking the time to clarify this you're
saying that 250 000 tests are done
every single day at the moment and give
or take a few
all 250 000 are being tested in the lab
i'm saying that the capacity is
200 and just over 250 000
this week over 200 000 a day
are being done and that's at that you
mean by being done
an 81 000 figure that you that you point
out
but there is a sorry sorry because this
is really important this is really
important and i'm
you know i thank you for taking the time
to clarify 250 000 tests are done every
day
tested how many of those are then taken
to the lab and subsequently tested in
the lab
now the measure of the number of tests
done each day is the measure of how many
are done in the lab
the there is a figure for capacity and
then there's a figure for the number
actually processed through the lab
and the 250 just over 250 000 that's the
capacity
and then the number done it has been
over 200
000 a day each day that's across the uk
that's both the uh the lighthouse labs
and those done
in the nhs in in all four nations
of the uk but the the big picture point
is we have the record capacity
the labs are growing but the
but the demand has also shot up we all
we all know that
and we're just driving that capacity up
as much as we can
but there's also this absolutely crucial
message for
all of your viewers which is if you have
the coronavirus symptoms
then you should get a test but if you
don't
then you should not come forward and get
a test unless you've specifically been
asked to
and i've seen reports of people who've
been in close contact with somebody
who's tested positive
and then thought i should go and get a
test and then i don't have to
self-isolate
unfortunately that isn't true because of
the
the um the virus can incubate inside you
for
for days and days if you've been a close
contact of somebody who's tested
positive
you have to self-isolate for two weeks
and if you get a test result that's
negative it doesn't change that
uh and part of the pressure on the final
question yeah i think
yeah okay one final question before i
let you go thank you for answering all
our questions honestly and frankly
health secretary
france you mentioned france earlier it's
generally a couple of weeks ahead of us
like italy
when it comes to covid they are reaching
capacity
in some hospitals in the south of the
country what is your
prediction for hospitals here in the
united kingdom by the end of the month
well i i i've seen the uh
the the reports of what's happening in
france and i've been in contact
um with our people in france to
verify what's happening and my heart
goes out to them
there is a great challenge in some parts
of france
and it just demonstrates that that as
cases go up
that inexorably leads to rises in
hospitalizations
here as i said the number of people in
hospital uh with covid is doubling every
eight days and um that demonstrates the
need for
us in government to take action and
everybody to take
this disease incredibly seriously uh to
avoid the sort of second peak that uh
that that we that nobody wants to see
how you feeling um health secretary it's
a big burden on your shoulders this
second wave
well it has been throughout and you
don't put yourself
forward for these things unless you are
are prepared to take the big decisions
and you know
my view is that the team i've got around
me are amazing and doing
incredible work throughout the
throughout the nhs
and that makes it easier um and my team
in government
and in the department is is amazing and
that helps
but ultimately all you can do is get up
in the morning
and make the best decisions you possibly
can on behalf of the nation
and then and then get up the next
morning and repeat
and and that's what we try to do look at
all of the
of the data and do everything we can to
protect
lives and livelihoods and and you know
i'll give you one example
if you have one more moment which is
that
we've seen this pressure on the testing
system earlier earlier this week we
could have
taken some of the hundred thousand tests
a day we sent to social care
and it would have reduced the noise in
the system and the amount of brick backs
i get in the press
but it would have been the wrong thing
to do because people in
care homes are amongst the most
vulnerable so we've we've protected the
tests going to care homes even though
that's created more political noise and
you've just got to take the best
decisions you can
um and i'm sure even your harshest
critic would appreciate that it's good
to
talk to you this morning thanks for
taking the time as always health
secretary thank you